[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to let me
go through a lot of changes to get made
a lot of rewrites a lot of reissues a
lot of re-editing and often that affects
what many people consider the most
important part of the movie since it's
the last thing people see some of those
storytellers agree it has to go out on
top what's doing so isn't always so easy
many movies either rewrite free edit or
even re shoot their ending to make sure
it has a satisfying conclusion meaning
there's other endings that change the
large outcome of the films sometimes the
outcomes are so different you just gotta
say what the fuck whether for the best
or for the worst
these are the goal turnit movie endings
that have a scratching our head in total
confusion and we're going to look at the
top 11 of them here today why top 11
because the ultimate version did Tesla
with focus groups this is the top 11
what the fuck open it ending
Aloha dr. Strangelove the Stanley
Kubrick classic had people rolling in
the aisles and questioning their safety
not at all like today politics but not
many know that this movie had a very
strange alternate ending
police are not this classic dark comedy
ended with a pie fight yeah no joke
or actually too much of a joke if
Kubrick bullet the scene was shot and
edited but the director pulled it out
saying it didn't match the tone of the
rest of the film apparently the world
still blows up but before it does the
War Room has a battle of their own at
the Buffy table where things get out of
control and they start throwing eyes at
one another the footage is not available
to the public but there are plenty of
pictures on set well certainly an
entertaining visual it should seem odd
and this was coming from a movie where a
guy rides a bomb down to the ground in a
film where a guy is strange as this
could exist this still just seemed one
step too goofy super weird to say the
least
such man is a Silva's are you wouldn't
think it'd be possible to even be
considered it is not totally possible in
some sense them as the song goes we'll
meet again but not with this scene put
it
[Music]
number ten
Looney towns back in action
yeah I'm really going from a hits on
this one the climax to the film most
people agree is one of the highlights of
the flick involving space travel duck
Dodgers laser lightsabers Marvin the
Martian Spy battles but the original
ending had almost none of them and yet
what somehow even stranger it's a battle
on the jungle where a magical device
de-evolve our characters resulting in
Timothy Dalton becoming a monkey Bugs
Bunny becoming a cave bunny and Tweety
Bird becoming a dinosaur who ends up
murdering our villain but here buddy
every yep that's all kind of grim its
witnesses got though it did have one
essential line that would have made up
for one of the film's biggest problems
the roll man dad this is Kate we haven't
kissed yet or anything we already get
along and we had virtually nothing in
common
that line fixes everything the love
story in this was done so awkwardly that
nobody could tell if it was
intentionally bad or not descending not
only says that it was intentional but
it's making fun of how little chemistry
romantic leads often have in adventure
movies it suddenly made what was mostly
painful to sit through a nice bit of
trolling on the audience so how strange
we have one really great idea that would
have saved one of the biggest problems
of the film in a clumsily handled climax
that's inferior in every other way I
guess that's just part of the give or
take process of filmmaking proving that
sometimes you just got to say that's all
folks number box
die hard with a vengeance sigh her film
ends like most IR films - shooting some
bad guys blowing shit up and saying a
badass line in the process because a
sucker but the original ending had
practically none event it was bizarrely
quiet talk heavy and even sophisticated
after Taemin gets away with his millions
he tries hiding out only to be
discovered by McClane you see he was
apparently fired from the NYPD because
they thought he was involved with the
robberies so he has no trouble putting a
Christmas present on the table and yes
that would make this a Christmas movie
like the last two and it turns out to be
a rocket launcher he turns the tables as
he plays a game of McClane says when
Simon gets an answer wrong he has to
fire the launcher hoping it's pointing
in the right direction seeing how the
aim was taken off it's so different than
a die hard movie would end this way it's
almost completely off from the rest of
the tone some people Satan that's what
makes it cool that it's a battle of
within a totally different setting but
others say it's die hard give us a
goddamn explosions I just wanted and
because there's a greater chance they
would sing let it snow at the end like
the last two but I think the ship is
sail for that with the other sequels
anyway breaking a Christmas tradition
good bad hard to say you need from any
other die hard movie definitely sir come
on
Titanic okay
there's already some major issues with
this movie particularly with the ending
where Rose dumps a priceless jewel into
the water yeah fuck all the starving
people that money could have saved it
belonged at the bottom of the ocean but
unlike the original where she performed
the act alone in the alternate ending
she has people around her freaking
congratulating her for it after a
reasonably funny line delivered by the
late Bill Paxton I don't know what to
say to a woman who tried to jump off the
Titanic when it's not faking and then
jumps back on when it is oh that is
legitimately well-written rose spells
out the goddamn method for us and it
still makes as little sense as if she
didn't say it out loud only life is
crisis and making each day count but
what makes it stranger is she left
though Paxton touched the jewel throws
it over and then he laughed joyfully
hahahaha
[Music]
yeah I'd be laughing like a madman to if
I lost millions of dollar to a crazy
windbag this makes everyone look like a
self-indulgent quick and recently
original it was her doing it in secret
here
oh she figured out the meaning of life
and you didn't pee ha ha God knows how
much money wasted on this exposition
there was your lost financers they throw
in a goddamn shooting star Oh blow me
that was get less fairytale shit from
the animated Titanic movies almost some
say Titanic is a masterpiece
others say is corny and cliche but
there's no arguing that this would have
pushed everybody over the rail that
really sucks lady numbers
[Music]
Alien Resurrection so for the most part
this movie ends like in the original
theatrical cut the island is destroy the
baby i'ts blues were apparently supposed
to feel sorry for it's destroyed and
they return to earth in the alternate
version though they land on earth in
France for no particular reason they
pretty much stay the same lines about
being a stranger to this world when the
big twist is revealed her earth is
blowed up to you baby yes I totally
don't get the point of this seriously
what did this add what does it amount to
if we're able to send tons of people in
the space hours so many people even got
pirates up there what in the hell is
earth just what to rot why would you
concerned about saving mankind from the
alien it look like we did a pretty good
job destroying ourselves anyway was this
the prequel to wall-e there's something
always had a nerve-racking when you find
out the action of the previous films
adds up to nothing I guess this
technically started in alien 3 but that
was just a few characters this is a
friggin earth suffragan earth what the
hell it's not like a tunnels made sense
in this movie but this would have been
the icing on the cake of pointlessness
you think you're a stranger replaced
well things don't get much stranger than
this number 6
[Music]
amazing spider-man 2 again must've the
overly-complicated plotted as gnomes
kept the same except for one tiny detail
Peter father is still alive what okay
this movie tries to throw every plot
threat it can at you and then suddenly
after the death of the main character
you throw this immediately after dude
even comic book me to panel to breathe
his life I had to disappear if you can
say yeah he has to stay hidden to keep
Peter safe apparently and only now now
is a good time to come out of hiding
yes sure not when his uncle died he
turned to a half spider his girlfriend's
father got ax and the city was in peril
twice no no only now was the time to
reveal that oh my - your own funeral
don't you think literally the sad thing
is we actually get some really good
acting from Andrew Garfield why the what
what say it say what you want to say
what do you want - are you bed - death
had to seem been in a better movie or
hell even just a better time maybe it
could have worked but as is not only
does it feel tagged on but it makes
little to no spidey sense
[Music]
number five Independence Day again this
one is very similar to the original it's
still a bunch of pilots led by the
President of the United States to take
down the aliens but there's times
there's a major change when Randy Quaid
comes in to save the day it's not as a
fighter jet it's in his fucking crop way
first of all that's the stupidest
fucking thing I've ever seen
second who the hell in the military just
let him strap a missile onto his plane
well sure you can attach that to your
crappy crop duster it's not like we need
every single missile available for this
mission and you totally look ready for
combat take ur shipyard in a movie
that's already pretty damn corny this is
probably the corniest thing you could
muster because this has been the moment
that was maybe too corny and might have
put people over the edge hard to say it
still has Will Smith and landmarks
blowing up that seemed to overshadow all
the other corny things in it but one
thing's for sure this ending deserves a
hard Oh
[Music]
number four clerks this ending is so bad
that even the director admit it would
have ruined the majority of goodwill the
film built up everything goes pretty
much the same as the original with Dante
closing up the store after big fight
with Randall
but the story continued that the guy
walked in after he's clothed takes out a
gun and fucking chooses he Rob's the
cash register and Dante dies bidding dr.
Kevin Smith admitted he just didn't know
how to end the flick and after being
recommended that he just cut that scene
off a little earlier he agreed it was a
much better choice yeah no kidding
this has nothing to do with anything in
the rest of the film it's not funny it's
not poignant it's nothing really that
dramatic it's just shocking for the
think of being shocking thankfully he
caught on to a pretty quick and it's
edited out because of this course
remains one of the most unique and
funniest generation and granted it's
probably one have ruined the film but it
would have been a pointless downer that
would have diffused an otherwise
hilarious comedy what were they thinking
who know but thank God they knew to cut
the final shot before the final shit
[Music]
I'm referee
army of dark the third film in the Evil
Dead trilogy knew how to keep the flat
stick coming there was a big difference
of opinion between the director and the
producer about how that film should end
because the movie was marketed more as
its own film and not third in a cult
trilogy the producer said the ending had
to reflect that so in the theatrical
version ashes the hero thing in the day
and getting the woman but if you know
the Evil Dead movies you know at half
end would ask getting screwed so in the
alternate ending he's given a sleeping
potion which will knock him out for
years and years until he returns to his
own time that's like a doofus he screws
up and takes too much resulting in him
waking up in a future of that well
similar to France in Alien Resurrection
I'm along hand the protectors I kind of
write about this ending if this was a
standalone movie the theatrical cut
would make more sense but as a third
film in a trilogy the other ending makes
a lot more sense I guess it all depends
on what you want to see army of Darkness
or Evil Dead 3 whatever version you
prefer there's an ending for each one
and they're very different so pick
whichever groovy version you like that
[Music]
number two
Little Shop of Horrors the original
ending to this movie has practically
entered legend it's amazing how
different it is from the theatrical cunt
timur sees his girlfriend from the
killer plants confronts him and ends up
destroying both the plant and evil
offspring saying the world seems about
right for a musical comedy with a dark
quirky edge but the original goes as
dark as they can fucking go
Seymour doesn't save his girlfriend from
the plant she dies and when he goes in
to confront them the plant winds taking
timur into his vines and eating him
alive yeah so both our main characters
are dead killed in bizarrely horrific
ways but it doesn't stop there the plant
allows himself to be sold all over the
world and when the time is right they
attack people are defenseless dust
that's on the plant grows bigger and
bigger until they completely take over
and gobble up mankind then what
something you are blind now this ending
is incredibly dark and remarkably
depressing on the one hand yeah the same
thing does kind of make sense for a
campy horror film but on the other hand
the music was so bouncing romantic and
even inspiring which I guess you could
argue just makes the original ending
more funny but really it's just kind of
a big downer the theatrical version
seemed to fit the film's identity a lot
more but yeah this is one hell of a
ballsy ending and you kind of got to
give it props for that it pulled no
punches it was all the way what people
have related to it if it was kicked in
who knows but it's out there for people
to see and you can decide yourself which
one is better whether it's the happy
ending or the good god what the hell
ending isn't out there experience all
the way
[Music]
as number one what the fuck ultimate
ending is I am Legend this is declared
as one of the biggest fuck you endings
if you're aware of the original story
I'll admit going into the movie I didn't
know it or why it was held at the
classic but once I discovered the
original ending it all made sense in the
film about an apocalyptic future taken
over by mutant people well Smith tries
to kill /w these mutants to find a cure
in a theatrical cut he sacrifices
himself to kill off them damn mutants
leaving the side characters to get
security discovered to the military to
start getting earth back to normal when
I saw this I remember it leaving no
impact what was the point in watching
this why is it considered one of the
great stories then I saw the alternate
ending it turns out the mutant trying to
get in was looking to save his
girlfriend shock that there's still
Humanity in them miss lets them go and
realizes he's the bad guy the new
civilization that inherits the earth
isn't made up of his kind anymore it's a
brand new species and he's the boogeyman
the rare breed that feeds off the
majority of everyday life he realizes
whether he likes it or not he is the
monster in the eyes of the new world who
we shit is that powerful
thought-provoking and challenging talk
about it I have the beholder message and
a brilliantly done wait even though he
lives in this version it's by far the
downer ending that a film about the end
of the world deserves but no the
theatrical version takes the entire
reason the story was made and completely
changes
I guess stuff like that has been done
before I mean look at the Disney film
they totally changed the meaning of
classic stories around but with this one
the tone of the film matches the
original ending it's dark it's gritty
it's heavy it's dramatic it really wants
you to feel like you're in a world has
been taken over by a new life-form and
your species is going extinct the tone
of the Little Mermaid is completely
different from the tone of the original
so we can buy the changes more but with
this one of course the original ending
is better suddenly everything falls into
place this is
just shot like a summer action quick it
shot like it has something important and
timeless to say but the studio disagreed
and said mankind rocked and we're going
to get our happy end what a letdown what
a betrayal what a total castration of
what made the story laugh for so many
years this is the not-so-great ending
given to a great story that should have
us all saying what the fuck are the rain
that we missed are there any you think
are worth we'll leave them in the
comments below and share but what the
fucker I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have
[Music]
[Applause]
hey does Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing the
best friends Animal Society this is a
non-profit membership organization
building no-kill programs and
partnerships hoping to bring about a day
when there will be no more homeless pets
the society leading initiatives and
animal care and community programs are
coordinated in Utah their golden rule is
to treat all living things as we
ourselves would wish to be treated to
demonstrate compassion and respect for
all living creatures and to judge our
effectiveness by the extent to which
animal lives are saved and improved on
they lead by example developing
promoting and sharing great new ideas
and programs to help animals if you look
at their site in their YouTube page you
can not only see the great work that
they're doing but also the cute pets
this great organization is responsible
for giving great vibes to click on the
link below and see how you too can help
a little critter
[Music]
you